yeah ask me questions  this is good and i'm going to give you  the real answers name one hazard the  corners of [ __ ] tables  um okay  um also surfaces he can climb up on a  couch or something like that and fall  off so that would be a hazard um food  wise what aren't you gonna feed him  heroin  okay true  is that not on the list  heroin any drugs what kind of fruits  shouldn't you give um  durian you know what i guess  an unchopped pineapple  because he could get poached  spiked correct  if i gave him a whole pineapple  you didn't mean he's like um be careful  with things like grapes why grapes uh  you know a choking hazard is not cutting  the grapes  them eating it whole yeah yeah whole  grape is really dangerous yeah whole  grape is very dangerous and that's  something that  you know here's the thing  i didn't think that through